thank you everybody for coming my name
is Matt Guf ler I'm a software engineer
for Google out of New York I'm here
today with Andy Glover an engineering
manager for Netflix and we're here to
talk to you about spinnaker spinnaker is
a recently released open-source
continuous delivery platform it supports
multiple cloud platforms out of the box
including comprehensive support for
Google compute engine so before we dive
into the particulars of spinnaker itself
let's talk a bit about the problem we're
trying to solve and that it is managing
the complexity of cloud deployments and
cloud environments make no mistake about
it cloud deployments are complicated we
talk to customers quite often and one
thing we hear constantly is that they'd
like to increase developer velocity what
this amounts to is dealing with the
volume of change terms of decreasing
excuse me terms of increasing developer
velocity the key is to reduce the
friction time between developers making
changes and those changes landing in
production there are many developers
changing systems all the time pushing
these changes and this is only going up
over time as organizations ahead
developers the volume of change
increases we try to reduce friction in
time as these changes are pushed the
various stages into production in
addition you have multiple services
being deployed independently
organizations are moving to a micro
services model and as these services are
deployed you have potentially an
exponential number of changes being
pushed into production exponentially
increasing number of changes in an ideal
world changes to these services as they
rolled out or isolated from one another
through our best a robust set of api's
still this increases complexity the
volume of change is always increasing
they're always more services coming
online also keep mind it's not a static
world things are always changing you're
typically deploying to cloud
environments that are being dynamically
scaled and the days when you can turn
off your service to do upgrades or make
changes or a long
gone so you need to be able to
gracefully roll out your changes while
you're continuing to service your users
while your cloud footprint may be
scaling in response to load and Leslie
you need to be able to revert changes if
something goes wrong as you do this
rollout you need to be able to
gracefully and quick quickly rollback
before you do damage to your business so
how do we handle this complexity it's
combination of principles practices and
tools the key principle is immutable
infrastructure and he's going to come up
in a minute and he's going to tell you
about how they employ this principle at
Netflix using this tool spinnaker which
we're gonna go into a lot of detail and
show demos but first let's talk about
immutable infrastructure of it so the
way things work you typically have a
machine it has CPU resources memory disk
some of this is virtual some potentially
real we have that machine layer on top
of that you have an operating system
layer you have whatever libraries and
applications your application depends on
typically something like an app or a web
server and then you have your actual
application and each of these different
layers can be deployed onto these
machines using different tools a fork
cloud computing really went mainstream
you would typically use something like a
config management system you would use
that to manage your web and app server
and then maybe another specialized tool
to deploy your application when you
would roll out changes you connect to
those running machines and redeploy the
application with the changes onto that
running system with the advent of cloud
computing and companies moving to an
immutable infrastructure model you would
never do this the idea is that in the
old days when it was expensive and slow
to build new machines we tried to avoid
building new machines from scratch now
that it's fast and cheap to roll out new
machines your provisioning new machines
all the time in the cloud so tearing
down a machine provisioning a new
machine installing all of your software
this is fast and cheap and easy now so
when you roll out anniversary of your
software instead of modifying things in
place which is risky you take the
approach where I have my new version of
software let me bake a static machine
image with that software let me move
that image into a test cluster let me
run my tests against it
once I'm happy
I stopped traffic from reaching the old
version traffic's only reaching a new
version and later on you can go off and
gracefully destroy that old
infrastructure anything goes along goes
wrong along the way you can easily roll
back just direct traffic back to that
old cluster so at Google we have tens of
thousands of developers it's 30,000 plus
developers changing things all the time
we have a principle where any developer
can change any part of the codebase we
have something like a Linux kernels
worth of changes landing in production
and weekly so how do we manage all this
change well we make new images we manage
traffic we don't modify systems in place
other companies following these same
principles companies like Netflix have
been applying the concepts of immutable
infrastructure it's been working very
well for them the majority of their
deployments are done employing immutable
infrastructure and the tool they use
primarily to make this happen is
spinnaker this is their flagship tool
it's a centerpiece of their cloud
platform and Andy's going to come up and
tell us quite a bit about it now and
then I'll come back up and do some some
demos Thank You Matt thanks a lot it's
great to be here is everyone warm enough
I'm freezing so Jess humble who wrote a
seminal book on continuous delivery
captures what I think is the essence of
continuous delivery and that's about
making deployments boring no longer are
they cross-functional scheduled events
that require a whole lot of people to
get in the same room and figure out
what's going on they're just simply done
and they're done reliably and the
businesses that are seeing that that are
taking advantage of continuous delivery
are obviously seeing accelerated time to
market they can produce products quickly
and get them in front of customers
quickly and because they can do that
they turn out to build the right product
they're not waiting a long time to
figure out whether or not this product
actually is a viable thing for users by
delivering the right product quickly
they're seeing increased customer
satisfaction and they're delivering a
product that's of higher quality and so
continuous delivery isn't new to Netflix
we've been doing it a long time and in
fact we see continuous delivery as the
as the facilitator for innovation at
Netflix we went to the cloud six years
ago and immediately saw that we needed
to start building some tooling so that
we could start pushing out software
quickly to you all and we started with a
tool called Asgard and Asgard in many
ways captured the cloud model for for
Netflix and maybe the industry in
general in terms of there's the notion
of an application and an application has
clusters and clusters are made up of
auto-scaling groups or server groups
Asgard served us well and served many
other companies well as well and we did
those see that Asgard lacks some of the
real continuous delivery features that
we needed so we embarked on another
effort and that effort was called Mamere
and Mamere added the notion of of
pipelines in front of Asgard and thus
created a bit more velocity with respect
to how we are doing deployments around
the same time Amir was built there was
yet another continuous delivery platform
built called edge center which the
Netflix edge platform team had built and
this was also highly successful in terms
of role in rolling out production
software to the to the edge of the
Netflix architecture so continuous
delivery isn't new to Netflix we've been
doing this a long time we've learned a
heck of a lot of lessons we sure know
how not to do it and we think we're
pretty good at knowing how to do it and
so about a year and a half ago we
embarked on a new effort to create an
entirely new platform from the ground up
called spinnaker and spinnaker is a
hardened continuous delivery platform
built to be tr0 for the business of
delivering software as I said it's it's
leveraged the lessons we've been
learning for quite a long time about how
to move quickly into the AWS cloud we
open-source spinnaker late last November
and spinnaker itself is is ultimately a
a workflow tool it's it has the notion
of pipelines pipelines are made up of
stages after you deploy an asset to some
end point you also have the ability to
manage those assets and spinnaker itself
integrates deeply with other operational
systems that can support telemetry
testing and performance monitoring for
example and spinnaker is built has been
built in partnership with a number of
companies including Google Microsoft
pivotal and Ken zan and these
partnerships reflect a deep integration
with various systems ie Google cloud
platform Microsoft Azure pivotal Cloud
Foundry and the these these partnerships
have been bi-directional from the
standpoint of we're learning from from
Google we're learning from Azure and
hopefully vice-versa they're learning
something from us and plugg ability is
key to spinnaker not only are the assets
that you can deploy with spinnaker
pluggable Netflix's has a very long
history of deploying a.m. eyes virtual
images virtual machine images but we
want to be able to play other things
stages of pipelines they themselves are
also pluggable we have our own set of
stages internal the Netflix some of them
are open source some Martin ostensibly
other companies will create stages that
are unique to their their environment
and ultimately the whole notion of cloud
providers themselves our pluggable and
and this plug ability is key for Netflix
we want to leverage all of AWS previous
tooling was very much centered around
easy to compute or compute we want to
take advantage of other services at ABS
like ECS s3 cloud front lambda all of
AWS is a fertile ground for Netflix
deployments and we want our tooling to
support it natively we also want to take
advantage of CDN
obviously Netflix has a very very large
CDN presence and we want to do we want
spinnaker to handle the deployments to
Akamai jars libs there are plenty of
teams that their that their end asset
necessarily isn't a service that
facilitates watching video but it could
be some some library that facilitates it
some other way we want to be able to
support deploying that that library into
like artifactory for example and then
not you know last but not least the
system needs to be flexible enough to
handle the you know the comings tidal
wave of containers and the good news is
the spinnaker supports all of these
through a pluggable model as I said we
began spinnaker about a year and a half
ago it's in production today at Netflix
and the success of Seneca is is it's
predicated on that it's a self-service
platform it's got a super easy-to-use UI
which you'll see that teams can go in
and figure out how to start you know
using it immediately they don't need
training they don't need some document
or a you know manual the ability for
teams to fashion their own delivery
pipelines there is no standard pipeline
at Netflix there's a there's a tool
obviously spinnaker that allows you to
create pipelines with various stages but
the stages that a team decides to build
is entirely up to that team so a wide
breadth of pipelines and then and then
last but not least because spinnaker is
open source we get to take advantage of
some of the innovations that you all are
building in your companies for your
needs and we've seen that already today
in that you know pull requests are
coming in and Netflix is taking
advantage of that so it's definitely a
bi-directional relationship and that's
why we choose to open source software
today spinnaker is doing 4,000
deployments a day Netflix has roughly
two dozen AWS accounts with a dozen
being accounts that are important for
streaming video because we have a
standard platform people can plug into
it easily it has a you know a
flexibility with pipelines more and more
teams are creating pipelines day in and
day out and that's leading to a
skyrocketing number in fact before I
made this presentation I thought the
number was 2000
our data science people actually
corrected me and said no it's actually a
four thousand so we've seen a tremendous
growth in deployments to AWS within
Netflix since releasing spinnaker and
the beauty of this pluggable yes there
it is
the beauty of this give this standard
platform that's pluggable is that
everyone at Netflix benefits from
spinnaker when new tools get online the
first thing they do is they integrate
with spinnaker and then all teams and
Netflix get advantage of it so case in
point we have a system a sophisticated I
don't have enough coffee and it's
freezing so that's my excuse we have a
sophisticated automated canary analysis
framework that team plugged it into
spinnaker it's a custom stage and now
everyone at Netflix gets to take
advantage of ACA and a sophisticated
form of testing before you go live
another case in point Netflix has a
container cloud called Titus for
obviously running containers that's
plugged into spinnaker now all teams and
Netflix can leverage Titus for
deployments should they choose to do so
and as new tools and services are built
at Netflix those teams are plugging them
into depth into spinnaker and all teams
at Netflix again get to leverage that
innovation so I said it was a beautiful
UI it's easy to use and and again Matt
will give more details but it's a
phenomenal UI it's awesome and as I said
it allows you to manage assets in
production so there's this notion of a
cluster a cluster spans the globe and
then you have server groups or aSG's
inside of a cluster in this case here's
a server group that's being it's in u.s.
East in Amazon and then there's us West
we codify deployment patterns again that
umbrella of innovation red debt red
black deployments which the rest of the
world calls blue green all teams get to
take advantage of these these
sophisticated deployment strategies
within spinnaker pipelines
this is the pipeline screen this is a
pipeline execution that shows a series
of stages that ultimately culminates in
a deployment into production spinnaker
supports parallel stages so you can
obviously run things in parallel you can
deploy to many regions at once did you
choose su you have deployment windows so
you can you can elect to say I want to
deploy this particular asset at this
part of the globe at this time of the
day all in all it's a very flexible
pluggable system and it seems phenomenal
its effects success I was having a hard
time here success at Netflix so I'd like
to transition it back to Matt we've been
working Netflix and Google have been
working together on spinnaker for about
a year and as I say that the innovation
is going both ways I'm gonna assume you
guys have learned something from us we
hope so and we've definitely learned
something from the Google folks because
obviously Google has a very interesting
infrastructure and belief pattern so
it's been a fruitful relationship so I'm
happy to be here thanks Andy okay time
flies it's been a year and a half oh
okay and a half so this raises an
important question why is Google
investing in spinnaker we've been
working on it just about a year and a
half we started with one person now we
have a quite sizable team half dozen or
so engineers program manager product
manager and so on so we are solidly
invested in this in this effort there
are the obvious things are our
principles aligned you know putting
these tools in the hands of the line
developers traceability so who did what
when where why and relying entirely on
immutable infrastructure so so these
things align but there's more to it than
that
Google is actively engaged in trying to
take things that we do well internally
things we've been doing for a long time
internally and making them available
externally but it's not as simple as
kind of hitting a giant red easy button
and just making everything public we
can't flip any bit to just share all of
our internal infrastructure so where it
makes sense and where it's reasonable
we're participating in open source
efforts like this one to try to build on
things that are out there that others
have contributed to and then get to a
point where we have these sorts of
internal capabilities avail
externally in the case of spinnaker
Netflix is a like a recognized leader
and the move to cloud so it made a lot
of sense for us to get involved with
this there are a few additional benefits
which might not be immediately obvious
as we've developed spinnaker the Netflix
guys have been sort of battle testing
this thing internally it's running in
production all the time so a we can have
a high degree of confidence that we're
not making breaking changes because
they're constantly testing this and
applying a significant load to it and
and be it brings some some sort of
common sanity checks to any kinds of
changes we propose we're not just doing
things sort of as we feel we're
discussing things we're working out in
the open and then we all agree on on
changes as we make them so and the final
thing worth mentioning is that the end
result is a product for our users and
our customers that doesn't rely on
unlocking into our platform I mean it
works with a significant set of cloud
platforms works very well with GCE we'll
talk more about integrations in the
container world but supports multiple
cloud platforms you're not locked in the
capabilities are quite similar across
all the different platforms so let's
leave that there one second we're going
to do it demo
okay can I have the demo laptop please
okay
I'll kick this off and then explain what
we're seeing
okay so this is a very simple web
application I'm going to make a simple
change so we can see that change
reflected and then I'll explain in
detail what's going on okay I changed
one local file I'm gonna change a
version number and then I'll explain
each step I just want to give it time to
to get going
okay so I have a local git repo it has a
very simple web application in it it's a
typical hello world whatever parameter I
pass to it'll echo it back and put hello
in front of it I made some change I
changed it from saying hello to saying
hello GCP next and then whatever name we
pass to it and then I did a local commit
it's a simple application but we have
Jenkins setup to pull every minute or
two on that local git repo and when it
notices any change was pushed to that
that branch which in this case is just
master it'll kick off a build and that
build uses Gradle packages up that that
application and then produces a Deb
package and publishes it and we'll look
at each of these steps in more detail
this particular web application wasn't
built by us it was built by kenzan media
one of the other participants in the
open-source effort so we can see Jenkins
picked up that change and executed this
build build number 25 so at this point
can we have the presentation laptop
please okay so this gives a kind of
conceptual overview of the different
components at work and also the workflow
if we read it from left to right
so I'm gonna start all that the left
I'll explain what I did so far and then
what we're gonna see and I'm gonna try
to talk slowly
which I'm not great at but the idea is I
want to let the bake stage catch up so
starting at the left I push the commit I
made a very simple change we'll be able
to see that change reflected in
intestine and production and then I push
that change to the local git repo
Jenkins picked up the change through its
polling builds that web application
produces an OS package in this case a
Debian archive and then publishes that
to a repo and practice this can be
something like bin tray artifactory you
have lots of choices for the demo I'm
running a local actually dead repo this
is the point where like a typical
continuous integration system like
Jenkins and a continuous delivery
framework like spinnaker start to
intersect so we're right now where the
blue shading begins to the left of that
baked box okay so the stuff in the blue
shaded area this represents a set of
spinnaker stages wired together in a
spinnaker pipeline and this is where
immutable infrastructure comes into
so we pushed the change our CI system
picked it up built it ostensibly around
unit tests although I don't have any
produced a dead package published a dead
package to some well-known repo we have
an option now we could shell into our
running systems upgrade that application
in place and then we have the new
version deployed but that wouldn't be
adherent to the immutable infrastructure
principles so what we're going to do
instead is make a static image a
hermetically sealed image which should
be familiar if you're familiar with
docker and containerization efforts in
this case is to VM image will package up
that image then we're going to deploy
brand-new cloud infrastructure so cloud
VMs with that image will test those
images once we decide they're happy then
we can disable or destroy the old
servers so why disable or destroy if
we're done with the old ones we can just
destroy them right the idea we're
disabled is it's a traffic management
operation instead of just destroying
your old servers just arrange it so that
they don't take any more traffic from
the load Mouse or sitting in front of
them listen if something goes wrong you
can quickly go back okay so make change
push change build the dead package
produce a static machine image deploy
that static machine image into a test
cluster so a new set of VMs wait until
things are deemed healthy and then
disable or destroy the old server group
there's a little bit more to it if you
look at the top and bottom so we
mentioned it works in multiple cloud
platforms the test here is running
against GCE so that's really the top
path so we're producing a GCE machine
image and then we're deploying a GCE
managed instance group in spinnaker
terminology we call these groups of
homogeneous VM server groups but it's a
managed instance group on GCE if we were
deploying an Amazon ec2 server group it
would be an auto scaling group makes
sense
so this is what we're doing right build
the code test it when you're happy push
it through the stages into production so
we're taking all these first-class
operations this idea of a bake a deploy
disable destroy we're taking all these
things and then we're building a set of
pipelines and we're using that set of
pipelines to have a system that takes
source code changes and pushes them all
the way through to production in a
disciplined way and leaves open the
possibility of doing a rollback very
easily and quickly so we roughly just
describe the first pipeline so we baked
deploy and in this case if you're just
doing a test you can do something like a
destroy you're not going to do a
rollback in a test cluster one thing
worth noting here we mentioned you know
we don't have it in mind to rebuild
everything from scratch we're trying to
rely on existing open source efforts
where it makes sense and build on things
that we consider the the Best of Breed
the bakery a lot relies entirely on
Packer from Hashi Corp we built a web
service around it but basically it's a
wrapper around packer that understands
naming conventions and versioning and
things that are spinnaker specific but
then delegates the actual work of
producing those machine images to Packer
so we didn't reinvent baking machine
images we're just wrapping it in
something that makes it a proper
spinnaker micro service and introduces
versioning and all the other things we
need for it to behave properly okay so
once that's done it's going to trigger
another pipeline and they're triggering
bit is interesting if you look all the
way the left you see that sort of
Jenkins guy and there's a picture from
docker it is you can you can kick off
pipelines with a choice of triggers
there are cron based triggers and other
things well once that pipeline completes
we want another pipeline to kick off so
that's a pipeline trigger so the first
one was a code push that pipeline
completes successfully then we have a
pipeline trigger to kick off this
validation pipeline for the purposes of
the demo the pipeline that does a
validation does nothing other than have
a manual judgment stage that says you
know validate everything's working and
then we'll go and click yep everything's
good once that pipeline completes
successfully we have one final pipeline
and this is the promotion pipeline and
this is where it really gets kind of
interesting so what we've done to this
point is push a code change via a new
dead package onto a new set of machines
into testing once we're happy with that
image and remember
not the servers we're testing it's the
image right once we're happy that the
tests have passed successfully we want
to deploy that exact same image into
production we don't want to produce a
new image we don't want to reinstall
that dead packet that dead package we
don't want to open ourselves up to the
risk that one of the systems we depend
on has maybe increased its version and
we get a later version that has some
protocols switched off by default
that's that's Cassandra so we don't
wanna open ourselves up to that we want
to push that image that we've tested
into the production cluster okay so at
that point instead of a bake stage we
use a find image stage and you give it
coordinates just say go to this cluster
find the latest or the largest server
group whatever makes sense for your
deployment gather those image details
and make them available in the context
of that pipeline so then any downstream
deploy uses that image for its
deployment and finally if you look at
the end of that last deployment we have
a deployment strategy so this is a
Bluegreen the Netflix guys with
patriotism call these red-black
deployments most people call these
Bluegreen so what's going to do is not
destroy the old server group we said in
testing fine we'll get rid of the old
server group no big deal but in
production we're just going to make it
so that the older server group the older
version of the software deployed on the
old VMs just doesn't take anymore
traffic still exists we don't destroy it
but it gets to be registered from its
load balancers and then if something
goes wrong we can quickly rollback can I
have the demo laptop please
okay we mentioned the three pipelines so
bacon deploy to test is the top one the
middle one is validate test and the last
one is promote to production so this top
pipeline is executing so we had the bake
stage there's the usual attributes you'd
expect what distro to use it describes
what packages being installed what cloud
platform is being targeted and that
completed successfully took about four
minutes then we had a deploy operation
could render better but resolutions are
a little weird so we're deploying that
image that we baked in the bake stage
into the test cluster so again you just
give it coordinates in this case it's
GCP next - test is the test cluster and
then following that as a destroy
operation and what the destroy operation
will do in this case is the terminus or
the target server group based on the
coordinates which will be just the
previous server group or the older
version and then it destroys it and if
we take a look at the clusters view and
this is very much like what Andy showed
only instead of six hundred or a
thousand vm's in each server group we
really went for it enough one in each
server group so I have no backup video
so playing it safe so this is the test
cluster on the bottom and if we look
here this is the newly deployed server
group and when you click on any of these
server groups you can drill down into
the details and work it's very
interesting as you start to see the
image information this is the image
that's under test okay that's the image
that was produced by that bake stage you
can see it in the execution details of
the bake stage and that's image that we
push into the test cluster so we now
have a new server group and you see the
old server group disappeared while I was
talking so that was that destroy stage
the idea is we would test this so one
thing we can do to test this we can
click on its load balancer capture the
DNS name or the IP address at a load
balancer and that's the change we made
we made it say hello from GC PMX off
that's legible
if we look at the production cluster
that's running above it just this one
and we do the same thing I have them
associated with different load balancers
so we click on the IP address for the
production load balancer it has the
old-style message so it doesn't have
that change so ostensibly I've done more
testing than just click on that and put
my name in but we're still going to go
to the manual judgment stage I said yes
we validated it we're happy with the
behavior of that image under test at
this point it's going to kick off one
final pipeline which is a promotion to
production pipeline and the first stage
errors find image and what this does is
look at that cluster which is the test
cluster say determine what image to use
and then it Prime's the context of the
pipeline with that image and this is
important when you configure a deploy
stage within a pipeline you don't put an
image information the image information
comes from context so if it's something
that was triggered directly by a Jenkins
job completing the image that gets
primed into the context is is associated
with I'm sorry if you have a pipeline
that's triggered from a Jenkins context
and you have a bake the bake produces an
image using the artifacts produced from
that Jenkins job and then the deployment
uses the image that was produced from
the bake stage so you never say use this
image when you have another pipeline
that has a fine image it looks to the
existing cluster determines what image
was deployed and then Prime's the
context with that image and that can be
used by downstream deployments but at
the point that you're never explicitly
selecting an image by name to use in one
of the pipelines it's always from
context okay so while that's running
we'll go back here and we'll see what's
going on
so prior to kicking off that final
pipeline we had two server groups in the
production cluster so we had six and
seven and six is now grayed out so it's
disabled 7 is still enabled 8 is coming
online so the server group exists but
has zero VMs deployed so it's still
spinning up and what it's going to do
when it does this deployment we said
there's a deployment strategy this
blue/green deployment strategy it's
going to take the old server group
disable it so it doesn't take any more
traffic after the new one has already
reported healthy so deploy the new one
wait for its healthy disable the old one
so it
associated from its load balancers then
we'll do a bit of cleanup and in this
case it'll make sure there are no more
than two server groups deployed so it'll
go and destroy any old just disabled
server groups beyond the one that was
immediately disabled at all making sense
all right so we'll let that run okay all
right
so we described a mural infrastructure
we describe some of the capabilities of
spinnaker some of these sort of
first-class stages like bake deploy
disable destroy there are the other
things you'd expect like resize enable
you can re-enable something there's
rollback there's a host the capabilities
all the things you see available in the
pipeline's
are really built on top of operations
that are available in kind of an ad-hoc
form within the UI so you can do
troubleshoot and you can isolate VMs
that aren't behaving and take them out
of the group so they don't they don't
take further traffic but the important
thing to keep mind is that these
principles while we've demonstrated them
here so far with virtual machines apply
equally well to a world built on
containers so we've been hard at work
and we have now an integration with
kubernetes far enough along that I can
demonstrate it here live and again no
backup video so it could get real
exciting but the integrations in quite
solid shape everything I'm showing here
is checked in so I'm running what's
what's committed at head basically
so anything we're doing here you can you
can easily try out on your own
so I'll kick off the demo and then I'll
explain a bit more about the kubernetes
integration so I don't want to run out
of time so I'll just get it going to
them all
so this is another simple hello world
application this time it's an go instead
of Java or groovy so I'm changing a
version number and then I have an
endpoint that'll let me see the version
when it comes up so we'll be able to
determine that we actually got the
correct version ok so I changed one
simple file
so I went into this very simple
application I changed the version string
that will be returned from slash version
and then I basically tagged and pushed
that container image to a docker
registry so in this case I'm running
using Google container registry it's
like a hosted docker registry makes it
easy to configure the credentials but
the important thing is that all I did
was just tag it and push it I didn't do
anything else the integration between
spinnaker and kubernetes relies on a few
different things the first you need a
kubernetes cluster so in this case as we
get into the demo it'll become clear but
we're running against Google container
engine it just makes it easy to set up
but any kubernetes cluster that you have
whether it's on pram or on AWS or or
using gke
it'll work exactly the same you just
need a cluster endpoint and credentials
to access it so the integration needs a
kubernetes cluster credentials to access
it and it needs to know where to pull
images from for that sample application
i'm using google container registry so i
configured my kubernetes account within
spinnaker to pull my my google container
registry account so it's just looking in
those repositories but what it's doing
is polling at some interval and any time
it sees a change to any image it pumps
an event into spinnaker and then if I
have a pipeline configured the trigger
from a change to any image in my
container registry it'll kick off that
pipeline and you can do the things you'd
expect you can make it listen for a
specific tag or all tags you can have it
listen for changes to multiple images
all of that works quite well in this
case we're keeping it simple it's one
image it's all within my same Google
cloud platform account and I'm relying
on the hosted services to make it a bit
easier so so I mentioned there are
different kinds of triggers we'll dig
into the pipeline here okay
so this docker trigger basically says
any pushed to a docker registry and
that's the registry to pull that
involves have changed to that repository
in this case I didn't specify tag so any
tag image will kick off this pipeline if
it detects that change it kicks off the
pipeline so what is the pipeline look
like it's quite simple there's a deploy
stage and we didn't look at this yet I
can show you what the deploy wizard
looks like this looks pretty similar
from cloud platform to cloud platform
the details differ a little bit but the
overall flow is quite consistent between
platforms it's not it's not a pure
abstraction where every platform has to
fit the exact shape but the experience
is consistent from platform to platform
so there's all the details you'd expect
you have to choose what containers you
want to deploy and it's just pulling the
registry so whatever's available in your
registry is what's available in the UI
ok you can associate it with load
balancers now all of these constructs
map to the proper kubernetes constructs
so load balancers map to services their
server groups we explained on GCE these
are managed instance groups on AWS these
are auto scaling groups on kubernetes
these are replication controllers and
whereas on the different virtual machine
integrations we described each server
group deploys VMs that really contain a
single instance the server groups in
this case our replication controllers
deploying pods that can contain multiple
containers so this demo we're just
applying one but you can deploy as many
containers as make sense for your your
pod ok and so on and you can specify all
the resource settings environment
variables mount volumes all the things
you'd expect to be able to do you can do
the nice thing about this is that we're
providing a consistent experience across
platforms and we're hiding a lot of the
complexity you can always drill down get
to all the details but you don't have to
bury yourself in all that complexity so
you're sort of day-to-day workflow as
you deploy your changes in a production
is made quite a bit easier so we have a
deploy stage and then we have a disabled
server group stage and in this case
while kubernetes relies on selectors our
labels so that's what we're doing we're
not disassociating it from a load
balancer we're changing a label such
that the services selectors don't pick
up those replication control
and then again a manual judgment stage
and I've been just as thorough with my
testing as I was before
it says validate it validate the test
voltage so same thing and we'll just
click OK when we get to it
and then the last thing is a resize so
let's go back see how far it got so it
did the deploy it did the disable and
now it's waiting for my judgment I have
very good judgment I'll say it worked
great now it's doing the resize so let's
take a look at the cluster view while
this kicks off so this is the cluster
and I'll explain a bit more about what's
on the screen in a second because
there's one other thing I want to call
out but you can see that grayed out
cluster at the bottom that was deployed
previously it was disabled so it's
grayed out the one that's resizing now
when it was first deployed it had one
container we said test it once we're
happy with the test we'll scale it up in
this case I scaled it to 400 containers
and it'll take a minute or so and then
you'll see they'll all they'll all
turned green but there's one other
interesting thing on this page so at the
bottom we have a kubernetes cluster in
the middle we have a GCE cluster and
then at the top we have an Amazon
cluster and they all look quite similar
all the health checking works quite
similarly you get show the high-level
view looks about the same but then as
you start to drill down you can see
there are differences and you can get to
the details if if you want so you can
see obviously the zones are different
and you can see the VPC information and
so on and there are context menus and
things everywhere that makes sense for
the selected resource types ok so that
should be deployed so this is this is
cruising right along ok so it's done the
koobideh stuff works very well it's very
fast kind of snappy and one nice thing
is we expose the amyl everywhere so if
you actually want to see the amyl that's
backing all these resources it's quite
easy to drill down on anyone
okay if I could have their presentation
laptop please okay so you can see how it
maps right
we covered the GC one and then this is
how the the kubernetes integration maps
down to the key kubernetes resources so
what we'll come back to the triggering
in a second but you're deploying docker
images or container images in this case
you're not deploying groups of VMS
you're just deploying replication
controllers and instead of containing
vm's they contain pods so in pods can
contain multiple containers we support
all of that throughout and the same
thing you can again apply those same
first-class operations so you can do a
red-black deployment or a Bluegreen
deployment on kubernetes resources and
the triggering is just what we said
instead of looking for necessarily a
Jenkins job to complete you can pull on
something like docker hub and when you
see a change pushed you know kick off
your new job clicker
okay so status um this was open source
november 16th 2015 quite comprehensive
support for Amazon's ec2 and for Google
compute engine pivotal has been adding
Cloud Foundry support it's quite far
along Microsoft Azure has a team working
on it we we meet weekly we're all
working out out in the open together
it's been pretty interesting trying to
learn from each other and you see kind
of the same struggles as we all come up
to speed so but they're they're coming
along and they have also some sort of
developer conference coming up where
they're gonna be presenting spinnaker as
well so again it supports a bunch of
different cloud platforms
so the koobideh support everything I
showed today is checked and I'm working
basically from head these are from the
published Debian packages I just built
an image using the host of the scripts
this is being used in production at
Netflix there are quite a few other
companies using it we have some internal
folks at Google using it as well and we
have a thriving open source community
there's a slack chat room that has it
must be a thousand or close to a
thousand users now in the general
channel there we have some some tags on
Stack Overflow and obviously there are I
don't know eight or nine or ten or more
github repos that hosts the various
services and all the
the projects that control it all if you
want to give it a shot on the Google
cloud launcher we have a quite easy to
use solution it's a couple of clicks no
configuration you'll be up and running
within your your GCP project and there
are tutorials on our spinnaker deo page
and on our cloud solutions page that
will sort of point you in the right
direction we'll all be available out in
the playground we're not sure where that
is but they said to say that after this
and Andy brought some of his guys from
Netflix so direct all the hard questions
to them and thank you all for coming
appreciate it
you